it was designed to be a show-stopping
arrival both in traditional dress the
flash of cameras proof this is a couple
an international crowds still want to
see stepping out in front of the
Pakistan Monument a symbol of unity in a
country that still has its struggles
Prince William recognized the suffering
many still face delivering a future
where Pakistan's great potential can be
realized will not be easy or without a
sacrifice for a country so young
Pakistan's endured many hardships with
countless lives lost to terror and
hatred tonight I want to pay tribute to
all those who've endured such sacrifice
and helped to build the country that we
see today everywhere that we've traveled
you can't miss the security operation in
place for this tour here Westerners are
a target for terrorist attacks meaning
plans of where exactly they'll go have
had to be kept largely secret the fact
they could even visit this school in
Islamabad is designed to show another
side of Pakistan and how children are
being helped through UK aid to have a
better future by keeping them in studies
William and Kate are well past the
learning phase when it comes to these
high-profile visits but at one of those
important meetings there was a familiar
face Prime Minister Imran Khan was a
friend of Princess Diana and in 1996 and
97 played host on her visits to Pakistan
that people still talk about today
William as a child remembered him saying
that one day he would be Prime Minister
similarly when I could be I was one
they know their own success is often
measured on these big occasions in a
country where visits by the Queen and
Prince Charles have also impressed in
the past with any of these big
diplomatic tours to key international
partners there will always be those
reminders that William's relatives have
been here before but as the week goes on
we will increasingly see that this is a
couple who want to shape their own roles
and define themselves as a truly modern
royal couple they are a close working
partnership who despite the restrictions
on this tour want to make a genuine
impact Rhiannon Mills
Sky News in Islamabad